40 year old alleged sex trafficker matt
gates was in the news again involving a
teenager but this time it was because
gates got owned over 2 million times by
a 19 year old activist
[Music]
i'm sure by now you've seen this video
of matt gates given a misogynistic and
fat phobic speech at the turning point
usa student action summit have you
watched these pro-abortion pro-murder
rallies the people
are just disgusting
like why is it
that
the women with the least likelihood of
getting pregnant are the ones most
worried about having abortions
nobody wants to impregnate you if you
look like a thumb this is actually
george carlin's joke about
anti-abortionists like mad gates but
gates tried to reverse it so he could
attack women and leave it to a
republican to steal someone else's joke
have it written on paper in front of
them and still butcher the punchline
also considering gates history is anyone
else concerned that he was allowed to
say this stuff let alone being a roomful
of teenagers now if you don't know the
history of butthead looking matt gates
here's some background it should come as
no surprise that gates's former high
school classmates described him as an
[ __ ] some even said they could have
predicted his sex scandals and others
they called gates an emotional vampire
in 2008 gates was arrested for a dui
after driving back from a nightclub
called the swamp
also this thing known as matt gates
coming out of the swamp seems very
fitting early on in matt gates career as
a politician he invented a sex game
where he and his fellow male colleagues
got points for sleeping with aids
interns lobbyists and married
legislators gates also has a habit of
sharing nude photos on the house floor
of women that he has slept with
you know typical behavior for a
hypocritical god-loving christian in
2017 gates voted against the combating
human trafficking in commercial vehicle
act
surprise surprise the guy who is
currently being investigated for sex
trafficking and having sex with a minor
voted against the anti-human trafficking
bill owen in 2018 gates invited white
nationalist chuck johnson to trump's
state of the union and when gates was
asked about it he pulled a trump and
said don't know the guy in 2019 gates
tweeted that florida's welcome sign
should be changed to there is no wage
that you can't be sexy something a
sexual predator would absolutely say
even matt gates's sister-in-law finds
him weird and creepy and when she was 19
gates tried to set her up with an older
man who was divorced and had a child so
then in 2021 a federal investigation was
opened up into matt gates and his friend
slash disgraced former seminole county
tax collector joel greenberg greenberg
originally faced 33 federal charges but
cut a deal with prosecutors and pleaded
guilty to six charges including sex
trafficking a minor in a confession
letter written by greenberg he says that
he and gates both paid for sex with
multiple women as well as a girl who was
17 at the time they provided cash gas
money gifts rent or partial tuition
payments via venmo also no one should be
surprised that this creep had to
literally pay girls to have sex with him
and in that very same confession letter
greenberg discusses asking roger stone
to help him secure a pardon from former
president donald trump for the price of
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
speaking of pardons we found out during
the january 6 hearings that matt gates
asked for a pardon for everything from
the beginning of time till now so
what is matt gates trying to hide and
how many crimes has matt gates committed
since birth and the pardons don't stop
there matt gates was also working on
getting roger stone apart him back in
2019 here's a clip that was recorded by
documentary filmmakers following roger
stone for their film a storm foretold
i'm
[Applause]
i mean i may have to appeal to the big
man because i got it's the district of
columbia
we surveyed 120 jurors 90 of them know
who i am and they hate my guts
[Music]
voluntarily
and then there's this audio clip of matt
gates attempting to sound like a mobster
[Music]
[Music]
and
the boss still has a very favorable life
he sends that message from time to time
would have been easy to make this go
whatever i couldn't live with myself so
jumping to this year 2022 matt gates
voted against another anti-human
trafficking bill the creep is literally
telling everyone who he is
again and what's even worse is that 19
other republicans voted against this
bill as well it turns out that fellow
insurrectionists such as biggs bobert
brooks gomer gosar green and perry
are pro-human trafficking in the span of
five years the republican party has gone
from one person being publicly pro-human
trafficking to 20. republicans creepily
project their own sick obsession with
pedophiles people's genders and the
lgbtq community this is the same party
that forces a pregnant ten-year-old rape
victim to have a child but then accuses
others of being groomers it's almost
like they're not so subtly telling us
who they really are and now that brings
us to matt gates body shaming 19 year
old activist olivia giuliana quick side
note i've noticed there's a trend with
republican men getting off on harassing
women alex stein eric greitens donald
trump donald trump jr i mean the list
goes on anyway back to gates he sent
this tweet with olivia's photo and this
my friends is the moment that matt gates
stepped in a huge pile of [ __ ] olivia is
one of the toughest and hardest working
activists that i know and she's not even
20 years old yet gates tried to own the
libs and what followed was a master
class in activism here's olivia on katy
fang's show so you've called gates's
comments outright misogyny and fat
phobia we reached out to the
congressman's team about those body
shaming claims this is what we got back
from gates's spokesperson quote
congressman gates never mentioned the
adult's weight leftist media did what do
you think about that official response
from matt gates's office
i think it's quite telling that gates's
office would try to keep the word
teenager out of the headline
time matt gates and teenager trended
together it didn't end so well for him
wait what was that
time matt gates and teenager trended
together it didn't end so well for him
olivia was able to spin gates disgusting
and hateful comments into something
positive and meaningful i mean it wasn't
even a fair fight she had him in a
chokehold within the first 24 hours and
within 72 hours of his attack olivia had
raised over 1 million dollars for
abortion funds and then just 48 hours
later she raised over 2 million dollars
olivia raised over 2 million dollars off
of matt gates's forehead and at the end
of the day sex trafficker matt gates is
nothing more than a loudmouth privileged
below average white guy who got into
office due to nepotism gates has
accomplished nothing during his time as
a lawmaker other than a very long list
of scandals you know people say don't
mess with texas but i feel like the real
lesson here is don't [ __ ] with texas
women way to go olivia well i'm gabe
sanchez and this has been what was that
[Music]
you